Let's discuss typical
firewall configuration.
First, let's provide some background.
Most standard applications that run
on top of TCP follow a kind and
server model.
For example, for
a simple mail transfer protocol or
SMTP, email is transmitted from
a kind system to a server system.
The client system generates new email
messages, typically from user input.
The server system accepts
incoming email messages, and
places them in appropriate
user mailboxes.
SMTP operates by setting up a TCP
connection between client and server, in
which the TCP server port number, which
identifies the SMTP server, is port 25.
The TCP port number for the SMTP client
is a number between 1,024 and 65,535.
>From this example, the port numbers
less than 1,024 are so called
well known port numbers and are assigned
permanently to particular applications.
Such as port 25 for
server SMTP or port 80 for HTTP.
The port numbers between 1,024 and
65,535 are generated dynamically and
have temporary significance only for
the duration of a TCP connection
from a client to the server.
Therefore, a packet filtering firewall
must permit inbound network traffic on
all these high number ports
vorticity base connections.
For the so-called,
well-known ports that are below 1,024,
there are protocols that use
the entire range of ports.
And in such case, the entire range
must be allowed in order for
the protocol to work.